[Music]
hello and welcome
to the feels good podcast with amanda
cerny
and yes my co-host jacqueline fernandez
is coming on but
she's gonna let me do a little catch-up
time with our special guest
so in this episode you're gonna get a
guaranteed dose of feel good fun
that will last you all day long and a
little bit about our guest
if you can guess who it is he definitely
will
make you feel good today and it's in his
business to make
people feel good all over the world as
one of the premier comics
comics sorry i'm drinking wine and in
fact
if you want to get a ticket to see him
you better do so fast because he sells
out arenas and theaters all over the
world
oh my god our guest was awarded the
stand up comedian of the year so he
hint there it is and
number one on the billboard charts for
his stand-up comedy album
live from seattle which i love
touring all over the world on his just
kidding
world tour releasing in his elements
which is a huge netflix hit this year
not to mention hosting his own podcast
the koi pond yes introducing joe coy
the jedi
i made it i made it i'm like still
scampering around though because i'm
like wait a minute this is the first
time i'm doing a setup in my
vanity amanda i'm so so amanda there
goes my calculation by the way
uh do not rely on me the reason i'm
super late join i'm so
so so sorry about this is because i was
like hey amanda 8 30 am my
time 6 p.m your time and all i saw was 6
p.m my time i got it
oh i got it jackie she's like just
relating that that that time right away
and i'm like yeah great and then like
i'm on my way right now to like my
my vanity to like my set and she's like
okay we're on i'm like
um i still have an hour 30 minutes so
she's like
feel free to throw clothes on just like
yeah i know
i deserve it i deserve it i'm so sorry
no i'm happy disaster
i like i like going after amanda even
even if amanda is right i always want to
make sure she's the wrong one
all right jacqueline yeah oh yeah
i mean like i agree i have a feeling
i'll be you're full
for that right after this podcast yeah
that's
cute jackie this is like
mine on this podcast
i know my type a inside of me it's okay
amanda
hey
joe was late also today nope yeah oh my
goodness
i was having technical difficulties
i was not i was on time
just break for no reason
does that ever happen to you does that
ever happen
bro but i don't even know how it broke i
don't know
and then i just nothing worse whatever i
think you're what i hate about zoom is
when something breaks
and it's all caught on camera and you're
like trying to fix
while the camera's so dumb
zoom is weird i want to be in studio you
know that right amanda i know he kept
telling me he's like we have to be
cool if we're in studio and stuff and
i'm like you do realize my co-host
is in india and we will have to
get on the plane yeah so
it was it was it was pretty crazy this
morning because like just
organizing these times so uh we made a
plan yesterday that everyone leaves the
hotel at six a.m
and uh there's a curfew going on here by
the way because of
like there's just it's getting out of
control again so
then they're like no you can't leave
till 6 30 a.m so we're like oh [ __ ]
and so all of us are like scampering
right now and i'm like oh i have to
reach out to reach really early and i
have to get ready for the podcast
so i was like in such a tiff like when i
got into my car and i was like oh i was
like really like frustrated
but then i put on your show
and uh i just i laughed it's like an
hour drive here i laughed the entire way
and it just changed my mood up
completely it was just like amazing
thank you so much you're so good thank
you
i appreciate it today was a good day for
me by the way i want you guys to know
that
oh that's cool wow tell us about it
all right so i got off the phone and uh
the deal with amblin
is done so uh i i sold a movie to uh
spielberg's people and it's what yeah
it's pretty cool
it's really cool and it's so funny that
you said that about that that's special
because
coming in hot i did it was my second
special at netflix and that's the one
spielberg watched
and uh and yeah so he watched coming in
hot and uh
he brought me in immediately for a
meeting and uh
you know next you know i pitched the
movie they bought it in the room and
and now here we are about four months
later we just
and that was today the the final deal
was today so
we're we're scheduled to go shoot uh
early 2000 2021.
this happened today i'm sorry that's oh
my god we're doing our podcast today
and not selling well i guess this is
like
hard to celebrate the best part was the
best part was uh
letting my son listen in i put it i put
the meeting on in
interco you know like uh what is it
called a speaker speaker phone
speaker just letting my son and just
letting my son hear it was uh
it was pretty cool yeah oh my god
how old is your son again he's 17 but
you know it's just like you know the
journey was so long i started
stand up but there was a lot of years
where my son you know he didn't know he
was three when i started
you know getting the specials and he
didn't understand what stand-up was
or or what that is but now he's at that
age where he knows what his dad's doing
and
and to be able to do that deal in front
of them that it was just so special
that's amazing we talked so hard today
it was it was really cool
so i love that my god that's amazing
yeah
such a close bond with your son yeah it
was cool
it was cool when uh when they said
spielberg read the script and he loved
it
my son just looked at me was like
this is the first place i've told
anybody it just happened like a couple
hours ago
that is huge yeah oh my god
like congratulations thank you great
oh my gosh start the show on my god i
don't know
remember like it's something that
could be oh yeah you're like and now
it's here
oh that's right i i went when i was at
your house i told you that
that's right and i was like it could
happen you know because it's hollywood
you know how it is
yeah you know they'll have something and
they love it in the room and then next
you know
cove it happens i thought for sure kova
was going to
i really thought kobe was going to stop
this whole thing i was so nervous i was
like
but the minute the minute spielberg says
something and then
covet hit and i'm like oh come on yeah
no i know he he loved it he was like no
doubter for everyone
he was like i'm going for it so so are
you back
on like just how is the situation
treating you right now
when it comes to like your shows and
stuff yeah it's bad hit pretty bad right
yeah the whole
tour yeah um you know i still have the
tickets out there we told everyone to
you know that they can return tickets
they're not returning them they're
holding on to them so we
it's crazy like we gave the option we
unders i you know i understand like i
don't want to hold on to tickets
so i told i gave everyone an option to
return the tickets and and
they're not they're holding on to them i
love that that's so supportive do you
have any dates do you have any like
i know but do you have any like
finalized dates no no the dates are fine
they've just been moved to they start uh
right around april
may of 2021. amanda we are so going for
those shows
what i mean i've been told please let's
i went to the one at the forum which was
uh in
sane that was so freaking funny and
the fact that you performed at the forum
yeah that was like a
huge bucket list item yeah
as well you know what was crazy about
that amanda is there was like this uh
and jacqueline i'm sorry there was this
uh there was this like uh
bidding for it the staples staples
center wanted me to perform
and they offered me a thursday and then
the forum offered me a
a friday uh and and then they they
they whined and dined me they were like
before you think about
just come see a show at the forum and
just see how it sounds and feels
like they gave me tickets to elton john
his last show at the forum
and the minute uh elton walked on stage
i just looked at my manager and i was
like
i have to perform on the stage with that
this is
elton john's last show is at the forum
and you're like give me that he retired
and i want to be on that stage i want to
perform i want my name next to elton
john they write all our names on the
walls
so yeah so like i'm on that wall with
him and uh
and that was that was the deal maker for
me just seeing elton john's last show at
the forum
and then for me to get on that same
stage was just amazing
wow how do you feel amazing like
huge things happen right and obviously i
know you work
really hard are you there's so many
questions for you one
how do you celebrate let's get there
first and then yeah yeah
i you know it's crazy like that i just
like to spend
those kind of things i like to spend
with family you know the other shows
it's like you know i'll have fun with
just
you know i don't know hanging out with
friends and stuff afterwards and
enjoying those moments but
something like that that was that was
all about my son that night and
and just getting him to come up on stage
you saw it amanda you don't get on stage
yeah i love how you include the people
around you your family
like personal and you could really feel
that and it brings
like the audience and even your friends
even closer to you just
even uh coming in hot with the
philippines and everything too
yeah you learn a lot but in such a fun
way
about different culture about you about
your family and i just
love how you include family oh thank you
because
that i you know what when i get off
stage a lot of people think some of the
stories aren't real
and then when they see a face to it
they're like oh
well and that is his son
and and then it becomes those jokes
become real
to to the fans so i love sharing my
family with the
with my fans when was the last time you
went to the philippines
when i shot uh coming up when i shot in
his elements
so the last netflix special uh i shot
there and and that was such a a a push
for me because they
actually wanted me to shoot a third hour
special
but i i wanted to give filipinos
a shot so i was like you know i got the
door open here at netflix
let me just go to the philippines with
some filipino comics that's never been
to the philippines let me show them
their culture
in person and then let them perform in
front of filipinos
and i also wanted to show the world that
when you go to the philippines you can
perform and people understand
english there oh yeah a lot of people
don't know that
i actually grew up with so many
filipinos and like they were speaking
tagalog
yeah i mean like they're speaking
english
and they're speaking almost speaking
spanish like it's like
it's crazy yeah i mean they had they had
the best lunchboxes i don't know if like
you had the best lunchboxes but
they had the best lunch but amanda i'm
not joking like in school every single
day
yeah oh filipino food the sausages yeah
they came to school every day with these
crazy like
manganese sausages isn't it
it's called loganisa so good is it
called
loganisa yeah that's so good thank you
and they were like they were always like
the best
artists in our school like they drew
really well
and like they were really neat i love it
their handwriting was always amazing
yes amazing i love the fact oh that it's
you know but the one thing that i wanted
to do is you know through my stand up i
wanted people to know that i was
filipino but i wanted to do it
indirectly
i didn't want people to just be like oh
all he does is compare filipinos with
other
ethnicities i don't want to do that i
want to tell a story
and see if people can relate i want to
tell my mom's story through
her just being a mom and then at the end
you're like hey my mom does that too
it's not about being filipino it's just
being a mom it's just mine happens to be
a filipino and
and that's how i wanted to get that
point across but when i went to
when i shot that third special in the
philippines i just wanted people to like
see our culture because we're not really
represented
i always feel like an ambassador when
people find out i'm a filipino i always
have to be an ambassador
and tell them about us but with that
special i wanted something
that people could watch it and be like
oh that's beautiful i want to visit that
country oh those people
are nice people i want to say oh that
food looks good and that's what that
was about just to embrace the culture
and just
give back to a a a a group of
communities
so much you know absolutely and i love
because she
included allowed all the different
performers on the special as well
like big chunks of the special too not
just like oh like here and go away yeah
thank you you gave them moments but even
touching going to shooting your own
special yeah i shot that thing i paid
for it amanda
which is amazing and i was hurt i was
hurt too i want you to know that amanda
you were hurt yeah i was hurt because i
felt i felt like and
you know i say this all the time so if
you know the people at netflix know that
i say this story all the time because i
love netflix now i have the greatest
relationship with them
i mean i'm already on my fourth special
i'm getting ready to shoot my fourth
with them
so they're they're great they just they
just didn't know if i was
what they needed on on that platform and
and that's great that they're supposed
their business you know what i mean
i had to go the extra mile to prove to
them that i belonged on that network
and and when you get it faced with an
opportu an obstacle like that
you pick which direction you want to go
you know
when someone says no we don't think
you're ready for this network you can
choose to go on twitter and go
you know what cancel your netflix
subscription
they don't want to give me a special and
hey or you could be like
or you could be like all right well just
give me a couple months i'll shoot
myself and i'll bring it to you
and and that's what i had to do wow i
was mad don't get me wrong when i was on
stage i was not happy
i was i was i was actually very
depressed on stage when i was shooting
live from seattle because i
just didn't understand how my friends
had specials but i wasn't offered one
but
you can never tell oh thank you yeah i
just remember being backstage and
looking at my son
and just like i'm broke right now i have
no money i spent all of it on this
special and if they don't
buy it from me what do i do with it you
know
so there was so much pressure on live
from seattle
i'm i love i love that you're actually
sharing that story as well because i
think like a lot of people
like to eliminate these like little
details about their journey and their
struggle
and just make it look like yeah i got on
netflix and it was great and like you
know they loved me
and you're like no it actually because
it really is i think like if you really
do want something
you you have to go out and get it you
have to make it happen for yourself
and that was that was number one on the
billboard charts right
it not only hit number one but uh it
changed my life
it was crazy i mean it went from uh me
selling comedy clubs out to like
selling multiple theaters out it was
crazy it was good wow
and then um you produced that though
i completely produce everything out of
pocket all of it
that's why i always tell people it's
like you know when you see
somebody don't just take it for what
you see in front of you try and find out
what it what it was that
got them there like really study and
take the time because we live in this
cancel culture right now where oh you
see somebody and they got something you
hate on them
because it makes you feel good because
you're not there or something or
whatever it is that
that makes you uh it's the easy
satisfaction
yeah it's the easy way out instead of
just finding out what that person did or
finding out that struggle
um you'll you'll you'll appreciate what
you got
a lot more when you hear something yeah
yeah it was so inspiring it was hard man
but i i was
i was happy that that that it happened
and uh and i always thank netflix for
putting
doing that to me because i i told them
when when they said no to me
that there was a fire that that was lit
like like no no
because the pressure was on i was 28
years in the game and i still haven't
had that
major special that pushed me forward and
i knew that was the routine
that could make it happen so i had to
make it myself and i was like i was
happy they did that because
then i became a producer because after
that the
the next three after that they they gave
me the money it was so funny when
coming in hot came out they just wrote a
check and they go do what you did with
life from seattle
and they they stepped back and just let
me produce it myself me and my sister
ran through that one so it was kind of
kind of cool so much more of a i mean
wow that's like
such a stronger business that you were
able to build through having to do it on
your own not only
are you getting like the talent fee and
the performance fee as a comedian
but now you're a producer as well which
is yeah a lot of the the money making
in hollywood is in production also so
yes like you're able to really provide
for your family now which is amazing
that's crazy you know it's crazy too
amanda jacqueline sorry
um is uh i shot i shot live from seattle
uh like in february right and then they
made me wait
and then i cut it up myself i think it
took me like two months to cut
and then i got it on their table like in
june
and then after june we waited
like the the process like when we put on
their table we waited
and then and then they finally were like
don't send it anywhere we're gonna put
in an offer and then
right away we're like okay they're gonna
put an offer we got it
we're gonna i'm gonna be on netflix and
they and we waited
right and it was right the day before
thanksgiving
that they said they put in the offer for
my special
so it's so crazy that i got that deal
with netflix my first deal on
thanksgiving the day before thanksgiving
and from that i'm sorry this is gonna be
a long story because i just thought of
it right now
that this is all kind of full circle but
if i didn't shoot that special when they
said that they didn't want one
if i would have went the other route and
and hated on netflix and
and and didn't produce it myself i would
never i would have never got the second
special which was coming in hot
which is my second special on on netflix
and since they gave me that second
special that's the one that stephen
watched so it's like you create your
opportunity
you know what i mean of course when they
said no to me
i could easily not have made this
special but i didn't i chose to make it
myself and sell it to him
and because of that i got coming in hot
and because of coming hot that's why i
got that netflix
that's why i got the deal with steven
spielberg and look what day it's on
it's the day before thanksgiving again
oh my god
oh my god that's a this is a great day
for you
this is crazy isn't this crazy
jacqueline that is
mind-blowing yeah this is huge for
all of us all of us it's like this is
the day
everyone celebrate cheers cheers
cheers everyone cheers
i have one of those oh my god i want one
done i'll send it to you i please do
oh my god i'm so cute boom i'll say this
is this like did you did you work on
this with a writer did you like is this
your biography
two and a half years it took me to write
that thing because i was on tour
but uh it it worked out chris farrell
helped me write it and uh
i i couldn't believe how much i put into
this
but i told every story you know
this this was therapy for me it really
was yeah
it it really like healed me and and
you know just getting in depth i talked
about my brother which i never talk
about
and uh that was it was really healing to
to be able to get those stories out
there like that
oh wow yeah i haven't i i got to read
that yeah i don't know
about that on the stand up no i never
have it it's such a hard thing for me to
talk about
yeah march so uh yeah i can't wait for
you guys to see
amanda can you buy it though i don't
want to give it to you for free all the
time
um i'll check with yeah
i'll buy it and i'll buy it amanda by me
one two
okay one two and send it down once one
comment below if you want a joke
what's it called the mix a mix plate
mixed plate
mixed plate next plate i love the name
you know when you go to hawaii they have
nick's plate and it has and when you
look at that plate it has a little bit
of asian it has some
it's got macaroni it's got it's got
korean barbecue it's got
my case as papaya hi it always has
papaya
but but that's that's kind of like my
life my life is that's that's my culture
that
you know when you look at how my
surroundings were and the people that
raised me
it's a big mixed plate man i'm half
white half filipino
you know me i got half black half
filipino a
uh uh uh uh
nephews i got you know it's just
everything i got latinos in my family i
got everything we're a mixed plate and
and i love it and that's
that's what that's all about
today's episode is brought to you by
clorox when it counts trust clorox the
same way we trust essential workers to
provide the care they give to us
our families trust us to give them a
safe and a protective home
our community heroes trust clorox to
keep places like hospitals and grocery
stores disinfected
so i know i too can trust clorox to
provide my home with a safe environment
at home we can all
enjoy that is why i trust clorox regular
beach
by mixing one-third cup of clorox
regular bleach with one gallon of water
when used as directed on hard non-porous
surfaces
it kills 99.9 of germs and bacteria
on a variety of surfaces from our
kitchen floors to the counters to
bathroom tubs to
of course laundry whites i know i can
count in clorox disinfecting products to
give myself
and my family the best home we deserve
i use clorox disinfecting products to
keep my laptop
and my home and loved ones safe and
clean
especially when it comes to high touch
surface areas like doorknobs or toilet
seat handles or even the remote
for me it's important to share with
loved ones and the public in general how
they can give
the most care for their loved ones
because
when it counts trust clorox
i don't know what it is vegan cheese
isn't that bad it's really
good no it's actually really bad it's
really bad it's horrible
i uh i love it i love cheese so much
and i'm lactose and i don't give a [ __ ]
oh my god oh what happens when you're
lactose
wait wait what happens when you're
intolerant when you're like what happens
to you yeah i'll tell you right now
it sounds like uh my stomach is
crumbling
it's just it's just
and i don't care you know that's not
what happens
i just look at my stomach and go be
strong bro
there's more coming down there's more
coming down
all right well a long journey you know
coming from like a sri lankan background
oh my god it's just like
meat is such a major part of the culture
yeah
and like having that in your curry and
having that as part of your diet so
it's a difficult one to remove because
like as a kid when you're
you're raised that way how do you like
get it out of your system so
yeah it's hard but i mean like all of
you guys have come from being non
we gotta get you better internet
jacqueline yeah
i think i think jacqueline is on uh
i think jacqueline is hooked up on the
moon
this is like it's like i was talking to
people on the space shuttle right now oh
you're frozen jacqueline
it's great oh i am no it's
such a it is a cute face i hope it's a
good frozen yeah yeah it is a good one
it's a podcast
this is like the complications of
everybody's reality right now
on yeah uh like everything
yeah the struggle is real but we
struggle is real
humans are meant to adapt
am i still frozen uh yeah you're frozen
by the way
yeah you've been frozen for about 30
minutes jacqueline oh we saw some
movement
yeah there's some movement yeah there's
no no no
i've been frozen for 30 minutes
that's crazy yeah yeah wait a minute i'm
gonna log i'm going to log back in
all right you jump back back in okay joe
and i are going to keep yeah all right
so you all right back in that was fun i
hope she makes it to mars
do a podcast they said over
zoom they said
it's going great but listen to this
yes they are i got a fun fact scotland
is the first nation to make period
products free
wow so no kotex no playtex
like no no brands you just get
free items right for working group
okay we have established an access to
free sanitary products
working group with membership drawn from
a number of scottish government teams
wait no
that's not what are you reading
thanks for amanda back even worse
[Laughter]
what is that i'm back thanks for coming
back as a robot
oh
and actually this frozen screen let's
interpret jacqueline's person's screen
uh this is when she found out that her
computer was on fire
this is when this is when jack lee found
out that that's not a computer screen
she's looking at that's an aquarium
this is when jacqueline realized that
she shouldn't have done the podcast
inside someone's closet
there's a hanger
very quick and observant wow this is
when jack lee found out
that those headsets actually belong on
an astronaut's head
she left
and the roast is complete success
well i guess
that was fun we should ever freeze all
the time
i think we will god that's great
jacqueline just don't talk
she's not even here in her defense she
is in the mountains
well here she comes she's fighting it
she's fighting because she doesn't want
to hear from me after
jacqueline you should have your wi-fi
prepared for that there she is oh she's
back
she's back i'm so scared i'm so scared
right now
hi
you're back on earth yep welcome back
[Laughter]
wait a minute like i know you guys wait
what happened to me last time oh nothing
um you were oh jessica you weren't in a
coma you just had bad wi-fi
becca you just have bad wife
jacqueline is acting like she was in a
coma for six months
what was it a car accident
no no jack please you just got dial
jacqueline was like oh we're gonna do a
podcast together
should i get dial up
but guys this is this is my this is a
dongle i don't know if like this is my
dongle this is my wi-fi
oh that's why you got a dong bong
dongle
well look i have full network
apparently i know why your wi-fi is
messed up
why yeah gotta move your hanger over
just move the hanger over a little
just move the antenna over to the left
of your just do it
guys i actually noticed that in the
beginning of the podcast and i was like
i i really hope no one sees that hanger
over there
oh we saw it i have a question for you
guys
oh i'd love to hear it you know how
there's
island time yes was there
um like oh yeah filipino time
for sure so it's not the whole continent
oh
my mom is uh my mom will be late to
anything
she'll be late to anything but here's
how my mom is my mom will be late to
something that she obviously knew
the time for but still act like oh that
was today
like like oh your birthday
was your birthday was yesterday
like mom you gave birth to me oh
you know when my bro you were the one
you you made me
so yeah my mom my mom is that person
late to everything
always i guess the filipino the
philippines the filipino
the filipino just one filipino by the
way the philip the mom the filipino yeah
hey joe have you ever entered the
filipino
hey i was gonna say a fact about the
philippines oh okay
seven thousand one hundred islands yes
yes so if it is island time i guess it's
like the most extreme kind of island
time there could be so it all makes
sense sense wow
there's a bunch of islands that's a
bunch of times without a
mind blown that was mind-blowing right
there i
agree okay wait i want you guys to cut
something up for me
what you remember when i told you that
they sent me to uh
when i was gonna i had to choose between
uh
the forum or staples and then they got
me to form brought me to see elton
john's last show at the
forum so that's what made my decision to
go the forum
guess what happened right before the
the pandemic what i made the top 10
list of arena acts in the world number
one was elton john and i was number 10.
what wow that is so cool
is that cool or what when when did you
find that out
it was right before the pandemic like
when they shut all the tours down i made
it to number 10.
and i was still climbing by the way
cause i feel like
coved was like no yeah kobe was like
we'll keep you at 10.
yeah 10 is good let's keep it
keep it low yes but are you
so are you enjoying i know we're
supposed to jump to fun facts but
are you enjoying this time of not
touring as much
yes this is the first full year i spent
with my son
ever whoa yeah first full year
and i've never seen phil how does he
feel i know
so funny right actually he loves it and
i love it we've we've never done so much
more
stuff together i i didn't realize how
important one day was
you know i always had that thursday
through sunday run
on the road and being with my son monday
tuesday wednesday and then you know
having myself
be on a plane on thursday night so that
was always my life
being in a different city every weekend
and i just thought that was normal
and the beautiful thing about this
pandemic is really enjoying
every single day with my son this is my
first full year ever with him
and i love it wow wow it's crazy how
we all get so caught up in
work and our moments and i know this is
said a lot but it makes me
like sit back and think and it's so good
just to sit back and think of this
sometimes but
because it's you think things are so
important
and you're like all right i have to do
this i have to do this i have to do this
throughout my day
and then when you take a minute to just
sit down and realize like
the years of life that you have the days
that like
are guaranteed to you or uncertain and
just the people that you love that you
have around your friends your family
and really just taking the time not to
act like you don't have time for them
but to make time for them
is so important and i feel like one of
the positive things about covet is
it made people realize okay
time is limited you know and we really
gotta just
put it with the people that we love
support the people that we love
and just put our time and energy there
as much as yeah
that's so true and if there's things
that you thought
that you couldn't do it because you
didn't have enough time coven
showed you that you had plenty of time
to do it and if you're not doing it
you're just lazy so i find myself doing
a lot of things that i never thought i
had time for
and you know and and or you know i
always found an excuse to not do it and
and now i found myself doing a lot of
the things that i've been wanting to do
for a long time and it's been great
um i need to go do something i agree
you're sick write something
for real well we can go into our fun
facts the jacqueline i'll let you
start start us off there jacqueline
awesome yes i'm here it looks like your
dongle's working better
ever since ever since you moved that
hanger i told you
yes it really is
oh three seconds
[ __ ] i know i s damn it
this is like the last time i'm using
this dongle all right
all right guys so if you guys have
number shut up
so number one random fun fact for you
joe
he's gone again uh all right i'm gonna
it's mixed with the uh jacqueline i love
you
but just smile god india is far
hey guys can i just listen you can for
this one you can until you get your
better dongle
yeah okay i'm going
fun facts unless food is mixed with
saliva
you can't taste it oh that's that's true
how do you know that fun fact wait is it
true
yeah i just i just assume yes
i would hate to eat something dry mouth
that was like
for me i was shocked oh really yeah for
you it's so
such common knowledge i don't know i
just guessed on that but i was just like
i would hate to eat something with a dry
mouth
that's gotta be uh yeah well it's true
so if you don't want to taste something
swallow hard and eat it fast before you
salivate
that's what that's what we say all the
time yep
that's what jacqueline says
one two there we go there it is
all right humans have genetic capability
to hibernate
scientists think that a human's ability
to hibernate may lie dormant in our
genetic code
oh i believe that it's gonna that's
gonna provide a lot of
excuses for people that are just like
sleeping all day
i believe it though i i think when you
rest a lot more
uh your immune system builds up oh yeah
i think
tired people get sick and and i believe
that i think we should all be like bears
bears sleep through the winter and guess
what they don't catch the flu
so you know what i mean they get up and
stretch
get some salmon and then go right back
to sleep so also
leaning on to number three chewing gum
while peeling onions will keep you from
crying which is great to know during the
holiday season
while you're in the kitchen that's a lie
what really
i think so it's gotta be well here's the
reason why
onions irritate the lacrimal
glands causing them to excrete tears
chewing gum while cutting onions
prevents tears by forcing you to breathe
through your
mouth this disperses the irritant so
that a significantly smaller amount
reaches
the lacrimal glands preventing them from
irritating enough to release tears
that's a lie
why do you disagree because i'm a mouth
i'm a mouth breather because i have
sleep apnea
so i always breathe through my mouth i
don't think i ever breathe through my
nose
every time i say that every time i cut
onions
i i can't handle it it's just i start
crying
i can have gum i don't care what you
have i i'll cry
i believe you and i'm very disappointed
in our facts because that's fiction
um but i
i believe you and now i also hear i
i hear the mouth breathing a little bit
i breathe through my mouth all the time
i'm like biggie smalls
i
oh wait so wait why do you have that
again it's uh
i have sleep apnea what is that it's
just like
i i can't uh i choke when i sleep
like i just the way i snore i just i
don't breathe i stop breathing when i
when i sleep so like my whole life i've
always
like i i forced myself to breathe
through my mouth so i just
that's how i breathe do you still
snoring he knows
yeah if i don't have my mask on i wear a
full mask if i don't want it
yeah if i don't wear it i i choke i i i
could die
it's crazy you've been training for
covid
my whole life your whole wow my whole
year old
i've been training i've been trying to
come for a while
[Laughter]
moving on i lost my co-host
it's fine i got all
yeah the world's healthiest place to
live according to the international
living
in shangri-la valley in panama oh
so it's the healthy healthiest place to
live have you ever been there
no i've never been there but why is it
the healthiest place the low cost of
living
significantly longer life expense
expectancy
a warm climate an active social scene
healthy food and a slower pace of life
that makes less for daily stress stress
i feel like kills yeah stress kills
100 have you ever been so stressed
uh you feel it in your chest yeah like a
pain like a sharp pain
sometimes i have johannes just press
right here
because you're stressed out yeah yeah i
hate that
i hate that feeling and i've i've been
teaching myself to kind of like breathe
through it
but i do hold a lot of no you know
because i don't
back in the day i used to be just oh
till it you know distressed like mad
no i just pictured you mouth breathing
through it
[Laughter]
when i'm stressed i breathe like this oh
oh no well at least that like
helps relieve it i feel like techniques
really do work
and then also yeah because that's kind
of what i do too because even when i
like do pressure points or whatever
because i also do here
and then yeah it helps too and i'll just
take a moment and just ignore everything
and i'm like
okay yeah it's it's
yeah yeah we got to learn how to like i
used to get mad in the car
i don't do that anymore because you're
not in the car
but you know what i'm talking about i'm
talking about driving yeah road rage
yeah i used to be bad i used to be bad
and no i don't care if you cut me off i
just slow down go all right get to where
you need to be sir
you just you just make you make fun with
it yeah i don't even i don't even
like i don't even react to it yeah like
before i used to react but now i'm like
oh okay cool i think that's what's
the best thing is being able to realize
our flaws
or recognize them and acknowledge them
and just yeah that we can improve
and it's so good like even for me
um with our puppy that's all i ever talk
about but
sometimes he pisses me off so much
because he'll come and he'll just like
raise their blade teeth attacking me
humping me left and right
jumping on me and i'm like you're like
are you talking about johannes
both
actually johannes gets very jealous and
upset
he's like he's like no that's no and
just yells at falcom more than
me in those moments but we both were
like okay
we even though we're so mad at him we
can't yell at him
we can't we can scream just to scare him
to stop
but he can't he's a baby and then also
just
people learn better through and people
animals learn better through reward and
um just showing them the right behaviors
like the right way to ask positive like
positive ways of training
and so really in doing that
he's been learning so fast he does it
automatically before we even have to
tell him
and i feel like people are a little bit
similar too
because like yes even my strategy would
used to be oh well you're doing this
wrong you're doing this wrong you're
doing this wrong
and then instead it's like oh great job
on doing this right great job and doing
this right great job
doing this right so kind of showing them
this is good yes
more motivating more motivating yeah
those are
usually the bad managers are the ones
that do it the other way
yeah i hate those managers those ones i
always quit on
yeah my manager she's just always giving
me positive affirmations yeah
oh wait a minute no no no i'm sorry
amanda
i'm not talking about our management
like now i'm talking about when i used
to work
oh yeah you know what i'm saying yes yes
when i used to work at like
uh nordstrom rack nice to
sell shoes i used to hate my manager you
know what i mean like
like no positive reinforcement it was
always just you didn't do this you
didn't do that you didn't do this like
yo
really like nothing you're not gonna get
anything for any of the other things
all right well i'm going to start
throwing shoes away
or taking some home yeah
that's so true i mean it's that's
definitely something you learn
throughout life i feel like some people
i wonder
if it's just something that they know
right away
and that's automatically how they manage
how they work things but for me
it was something that was learned for
sure this is even the way and i
manage stuff i'm like oh do this because
for me i'm i'm a perfectionist
like i want everything to be great and
i'm always
like i would always be like oh this and
this and this and this got to work on
this that has to be better and then
yeah i noticed things improving when it
was more like great job on this oh that
was amazing
but it's not to say not to highlight not
to not
highlight um when people are really
effing up
but because i think that's important too
right like oh yeah
you manage your whole business you
manage like
you have to like a lot of people look at
talent and they're like oh they're
just talent but you need to oversee the
things that are going on in your in your
worlds
what are what is some advice that you
could give to somebody that's new to
doing now or even
influencers that are new to doing that
and how much trust they should have
and i you know my number one role
for me and i learned through experience
is keep your circle tight
you know trust is a a hard thing to give
especially
when you get to a certain level right
does that make sense and
it's hard to trust people you know and
you know when when you have someone that
you do trust value that person
and really cherish who you have in your
team
uh you do a great job of that i remember
even
um your social media guy came over with
you too
and you were just like praising him
yeah the time like shouting him out like
giving him credit
like and you know and you can tell
you you guys have a good relationship
and he appreciated the support like
you're very supportive i noticed yeah
i mean i i you know there's those times
where you you have disputes right but
you always have to make sure that
you uh show the appreciation just like
you said earlier
you know what i mean it's like hey yeah
this was messed up with eight i
appreciate you you're
you're great you know what i mean let's
do this let's do that
and um yeah and like like you said
jacob's great
you know and and yeah i'm horrible with
names
no that's fine but it was cool that you
pointed that out you know because
there's times
you know where i'll get mad but then i
also let them know like
dude you're a genius like you know we
messed up and that's fine
it'll work out and yeah have that
balance but i also understand that i
need him
you know yeah i need him and he's very
important so
a lot of people seem to forget that yeah
that's when the business goes bad
yep can't be a one-man show especially
once you grow that's
it limits you yeah my manager joel you
know i failed to
mention him you know with a live from
seattle but i always tell people like
he's the one that said we got the money
you know you have the money go let's go
let's shoot it and and he was he's
another reason why i did that that
live from seattle was because of my
manager he was amazing to
to make that call and and have the
confidence in me to
to to shoot that that special i know i
keep going back
on that but but i like how we're talking
about this topic it's like
you know if there's anything that you
can do in this business it's keep your
circle tight and appreciate who you have
totally yeah yeah like even for me
you know i'm able to focus more on
creatives now and
it was definitely something i built but
with my manager
lacey like i i talk about her all the
time because i'm obsessed with her and i
i really do trust her and trust with me
it's like something that's definitely
earned yeah i think it should be with
everybody
and i usually give it like a a good
depending on how much you interact or
you're around with
around somebody and you also pay
attention to situations and just be
observant
because that's where it really shines
through but i
like so it's hard to put like a time
stamp on when you can begin to trust
somebody but
for me it's always been like a good
year and a half or so or a year probably
a year
of like being around somebody a lot
talking to somebody a lot to really just
let loose or some people you do right
away too but like i
still that's being a little bit naive in
my mind
but maybe that's negative i don't know
no it's a little different in our
situation i think right yeah
we're just saying this for anybody you
should be like that but like
you know when you get to like you know
where we're at right now
it's it's it's more like we got to be
god i hate saying this stuff but it's
like we have to be careful with our
friendships
right because it's not like how it was
when uh
when we were in high school or you know
where you were just meeting friends now
there's some people that just want to
meet us because there's something that
they want
and there's something that they want to
be a part of and it's up to us to try
and dice you know
figure that out and it sucks that we
have to do that and it depends how
people approach you too if they approach
you approach you directly
about something that's one way but if
they try to do it in a sly
roundabout way i feel like that's always
the worst way worst way
yeah just be direct be direct man and be
cool
and be you yeah be you be genuine
like just be genuine but like when you
the thing is we see
you and i have seen that approach a
billion times
so it's like when you're being sly we
see it we we know
yeah we know that angle we've been there
we've seen that
so yeah and it's honestly
it's not as like that i don't know like
everybody trash talks hollywood and
stuff and says it's horrible and i
okay but it's perspective right yeah i
guess that every situation
every town you're in every job you have
your perspective is what your reality is
so i guess that is kind of what you make
it and if i'm going around
thinking everybody sucks everybody wants
to use me i'm kind of putting that
energy out there too
yes so again it goes back to balance i
think
the story is balanced with everything no
you can put amanda you
you're very uh your personality is uh
very warm like you you stay genuine like
you are who you
like when i first met you you're the
same person i saw
you know like when i watched stuff that
you did with batch and
you know what i mean like like like i
always told you right when i met uh when
i first met you i was like dude
you cracked me up and then to see that
person in person
you're you're genuinely that person and
i think you're like that with anybody
that you meet and i and i and i try and
be that way too you know
yeah i mean why not no but there's
that i think that's what you're trying
to say though like you know when we come
to hollywood
we do see those people there are people
that you see and you're like oh this
man i love it i can't wait to meet that
person and then you meet him you're like
yeah it's bad yeah there's there's a few
where i'm like
really i looked up to you man like why'd
you do this why'd you
why'd you end this for me you know what
do they say it's always you never beat
your heroes
there it is and it sucks and
it makes me not want to meet some you
know because of the
ones that i have been i'm like wow why
are you like that
yeah i mean if i ever get the
opportunity to meet angelina jolie
i guess i would well you're gonna
is she not there she's not here oh
she never was you know i thought she
would be in your man cave
but which you got a new man cave by the
way joe i could talk to you forever
but the fact that like my host dropped
off my co-host
[Music]
she even it's so sad she sent me a text
also and
yeah um what did she say
i'm just listening
um but yeah so she's so sweet
though isn't she she's awesome that was
your first time meeting her right
yeah she's so great yeah we'll have a
hang sesh whenever like
kobe's over and all this like
comes to an end very soon and maybe at
one of your shows
because i was loving vaccines that are
going to work and going to be greater
coming out hopefully
yes and which is i can't wait we kind of
got some good news with vaccines
yeah we'll see yeah i'm not trying it
yet
but i'm not i'm awake yeah i'm gonna
wait too
i gotta hold off do you do flu shots and
stuff
i never do flu shots you do i never and
guess what
i never got the flu neither did i
but doctors are gonna hate us for this
they're gonna be like why people need it
but
i don't maybe you should screen the
people that need it but i don't need it
yeah i'm gonna knock on wood though yeah
just in case
yeah but thank you so much for coming on
joe sorry for the technical difficulties
you made it so fun like always guys make
sure you check out joe
at joe coy right you got your username
on instagram
good for you a lot of people have
underscores so i'm very proud of you
for being early to that maybe jacob
helped you thank you
shout out to jacob yes guys get his
book which is coming out soon look at
his tour dates coming up we got mixed
plate
so check all that good stuff out joe's
hilarious go
and oh little joe and the funko
yes get those too which i have mine
right above
my stove where i will cook my
rice which are you is that out
it's coming out it's coming out soon
yeah i wanna
i can't wait let's do a commercial
together i mean
you to this day you know i tell you how
to make rice
he still measures it like just to there
and perfect rice that's so awesome yeah
i love you joe thank you guys for
watching and
jacqueline thanks you too and bye
jacqueline
1000 two one thousand three one thousand
okay
[Music]
bye